welcome to episode 97 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i interviewed duduzani
zuma
duduzoni zuma is an incredibly
controversial figure
by far the most nerve-wracking interview
i've ever done
as you guys may know south africa is
rioting
a big reason for that that you can read
about all over the news
is that jacob zuma the former president
of south africa
has been incarcerated duduzani zuma is
jacob zuma's son
i had the opportunity to speak with him
and i couldn't say no to something this
serious he's in the middle of a
countrywide catastrophe
this is an interview i was very anxious
about doing
and releasing given the controversy but
i think the world is an insanely
complicated place
and one where suffering is all too
common i firmly believe that one of the
ways to ameliorate
suffering is to hear people speak openly
i've never trusted news outlets to tell
the full story good or bad
podcasts allow long-form content and i
think the more clear stories you can
hear from people
the easier you can think i did this
interview because i think hearing people
talk
openly is important i don't necessarily
agree or disagree with opinions on my
podcast
including this episode and going forward
i'd like you guys to remember that
truth be told i don't know enough about
the situation in south africa right now
to have a well-informed opinion or to
take any position
hopefully doing this interview gives
some people looking for more information
more information
this interview allows one side of the
story to come out and while i'm well
aware that many people are unbelievably
hurt and angry
i believe more uncensored information is
always better even if you don't agree
with what's being said or who's saying
it
i hope i can have more conversations
like this it would be amazing to have a
platform where people could speak openly
no matter what so here it goes
welcome to my podcast michaela peterson
very good to meet you man thank you very
much for having me
okay so i've got to say i'm a bit
anxious about this
but i think long-form conversation is
incredibly important so i'm also excited
um but before we get started you better
give a brief background about who you
are
and what you do uh thank you very much
for
for the intro before i give the
background
i am very thankful for this opportunity
um you and your team have
afforded me a voice where many people
are failing to do so so i thank you very
much for that
um i'm from south africa um
i'm a businessman i've been an
entrepreneur in my pretty much my adult
life my whole adult
life
spanned the sectors of i.t information
technology
mining in the coal space uranium space
gold in the manufacturing space
there's some defense manufacturing
marmot personnel vehicles
so vehicles for the defense sector
as well as the media space we owned at
one point
a 25 news channel called the n7
and a daily weekly print newspaper
called the new age
and that's pretty much what's kept me
busy for the better part of my business
life i'm from a political family in
south africa my father was
the former president of the republic of
south africa and he's a long-standing
political activist you know i mean is
known for
his work inside and outside the country
as a political activist
in the pre-apartheid time i think in a
nutshell that's
that's who i am i'm a family man
married or a wife got kids and
yeah that's my story in a nutshell okay
we're gonna get into that um i think
what would be helpful for my audience is
probably to give a brief background
about what's happened in
south africa this isn't this might be
tricky but in the last
you know 75 years or so because
i don't think most people especially a
lot of people in the west know
exactly what went on and what the
apartheid is
or was so just maybe brief background
about the last 75 years and then we'll
get into some more specifics
cool not a problem i'll do that um i'm
39 years old so i may be sketchy here
and there so guys will have to forgive
me
um so south africa
over the past 75 years has gone through
a very interesting transition multiple
transitions
i think south africa is a history as you
know
and the ones that don't was colonized
when when the the dutch arrived in 1652
and that's where the history of south
africa really
is um has been pointed from and
the fallouts and the gains from from
that period
just from a point of race relations and
as well as
tribalism as it exists in the country
today and how that has played a major
part in politics and still plays a major
part
in our politics as well as our economics
in this country
so the past 75 years being probably the
most pivotal
um there's been there's been a
transition from
what would be the apartheid government
at that time to
what is the new dispensation after the
dawn of democracy in 1994
but preceding that um that period
there was a formation of a liberation
movement called the african national
congress which is the anc
is a political party that i'm a part of
that my father's part of and my family's
been a part of and many other people
and i think the most notable face an
iconic face-off of their political
movement is
the late um dr nelson mandela that party
was formed in 1912
and the reason i mentioned that is
because that is quite
relevant to the history of of the
country
over the past 75 years so
leading up from 1912 up till the
apartheid government really
took over from what would have been
english rule at the time
they formed their government that was um
a government of subjugation to the black
people of south africa the indigenous
people
um and that subjugation was based on um
an institutionalized necessary
institutionalized systematic
approach to to what the country was
about
which formed its economic landscape and
its um
social landscape which now obviously is
known as its
socio-economic landscape and the
remnants there off
as we see it up until today
activists were pushing for the freedom
of a country for a very long time
i know a lot of political information
that some formed over that period
there was an apartheid government that
was in charge
and they they were developing the
country according to
racial lines so if you are in south
africa and you take a look around
there's still a lot of
of remnants of that in the way that
cities have been built
um in the way that um the town planning
and
and the logistics so whether it's its
road or rail has been
developed um and that speaks volumes
because it
i think it'll lead to part of our
conversation um a bit later um on
why um some of those um remnants are
still relevant today
um as much as i'm not someone that
believes in holding um in the past
or our history good or bad holding
holding us ransom
there are some issues that still are are
unresolved and
matters that haven't been dealt with by
the previous government and
unfortunately by the current government
so
i think the pivotal time was in that
came around was in 1976
and the beginning of of what would have
been
a revolution by the youth at that time
so the 76th generation is the youth
um high scholars in the main um so early
teens and teenagers
that revolted against the educational
system at that point
which was particularly aimed at a
language
which is known as a a dutch settler
language
it's called afrikaans which was which is
a derivative of dutch
basically in south africa um and that
is what snowballed into the later part
of the revolution which um culminated in
the negotiations
in from the early 90s and then the
release of
political prisoners and dr nelson
mandela
at that time and then the democrat the
first democratic
democratic elections in 1994
where for the first time in the south
african history there was a
a black government that was um
representative of
what is known as as the majority in the
country and it leads us to
2021 where we we are today so there have
been some lessons that we've we've
learned good and bad
some painful and some humorous
but i think what what we've tried to do
over a period of time
is to undo the legacy of apartheid as
they call it
so educational system the the financial
and economic structures
um in trying to to give people uh black
people their dignity back
um social housing programs there's a
high rate of unemployment
which is something that um you know
everyone has tried to deal with
and that is that is basically where
we're at that's the history and
they're always two sides of the story i
mean we're still trying to get to the
final version because i think
um none of us none of us um have gotten
to that to that version even though
we believed we had in 94 i think
that was far from from a reality and i
think today um the time we live in that
speaks
of of that um that fast economic sector
okay so what is happening today like i
know south africa has been in the news
in a pretty intense way to say the least
in the last
you know month or so although
periodically for a long time
but um like what's happening now
um miss peterson right now um
i think what is being beamed the image
is being beamed across
um the world is a series of
of um protest actions that have
resulted in unrest and you know getting
getting to the bottom of it is what
everyone is trying to do but i know i've
got my own
um version of events um that believe
that i believe has gotten us to this
point
but if i may take it um a step back so
my father
has been um and then myself we've been
part of
quite a long journey of um criticism
and negative media in this country
um him specifically because he's been in
government for a long time mine has just
been
probably in the past let's call it seven
years
you know because of my my business
dealings and my perceived proximity to
him and how that is how that supposedly
resulted in favorable transactions at my
side which is the furthest thing from
the truth
um i've been alleged of a whole host of
things
corruption fraud you name it money
laundering racketeering
and these these claims obviously claims
that i refute i've been to
a court of law i've been to update what
is called the commission of inquiry
state capital commission of inquiry
um they tried to to ascertain
who the culprits were if there were any
and and um
and what the transactions were until
this day um
um unclean um as much as people refused
to believe it and still want to
to to point fingers but that's that's
the case i've faced the music
um i've been living in in dubai for the
past five years
because i haven't had the opportunity to
live here based on on
on issues that resulted from that um my
bank account so close so i
do not exist i did not exist up from
2015
um economically or in the financial
system um up until now
um i do not exist because my bank
accounts are shut
so my father's gone through a whole host
of cases
and what has resulted to where we are
today is that um
he's been uh he was arrested and
actually wasn't arrested he was
incarcerated for what is called the
contempt of court
where he allegedly refused to appear in
front of a court to answer for whatever
transgressions
that court being the commission the very
same commission commissioner of inquiry
which is
an inquisitorial body that will give
reference or
recommendations to to prosecutors or law
enforcement agencies
on how to proceed so he was in contempt
of that commission
and he's been sentenced to 15 months in
in prison and he's currently
sitting in prison so his arrest sparked
um the initial part of the protests
um which was uh there was a free jacob
zuma
uh movement that that popped up um
people that
were trying to hit back at his
detractors and people that were just
trying to
to rally support for him for his release
and his unfair
incarceration um which i which i support
as
as in being my father besides everything
else and then from there
is how the unrest has has taken a
different turn and has become um
full scale a full-scale civil unrest
where we've seen the imagery
of of destruction we've seen and we've
seen depth as well
and those are attributed to his
incarceration
and more importantly for this
conversation attributed to me as
all and i've been um amongst
a handful of people but i've taken i've
taken the blame for what's happened in
south africa which is
which is far from the truth
okay so you said people
he said hit back at his detractors
so who would these detractors be so the
detractors would be
political opponents as i understand it
political opponents
within his organization it would be
what what a lot believe are his um
opponents
within the judicial system that have
given him an unfair
um role of the dice um and
yeah in the main that's what that that's
what would be an opposition parties of
course that exists in the country
yeah okay so before we get into all that
because
that is a lot uh
do you have any social media accounts
miss peterson i don't have any social
media accounts that do not exist
on instagram um what else is there
facebook twitter no especially the
twitter one because there's a twitter
that's been
uh making the rounds for for some time
now and if you'd allow me just to
speak on that so i give some some
context and clarity to that
um the first time so there's a lot of
twitter accounts that exist
under under my my name which are false
accounts as well
and one of them has gained notoriety
over a period of time and it
has gained um a following as as a fake
account
um and over a period of time has been
tweeting a whole
range of things and it was first brought
to my attention by a friend of mine and
i tried dealing with the situation the
best i could he tried reporting it to
to twitter i got other people friends of
mine
um across the world to do so as well and
i thought the situation was dealt with
and it wasn't
and eventually it resulted
in me
so it was um at a court case and as well
as a commission of inquiry as well on
the sidelines with the media because
they asked look
there's a lot being said on your social
media account and i made it clear
i'm not on social media and that
specifically that account that exists
is not my social media my sorry my
twitter handle and it's not my account
um i've said that to a number of
journalists over a period of time and
they've cheated
fake account um i've mentioned this on
on numerous
interviews um other podcasts
tv interviews to different presenters
and hosts
print media interviews radio interviews
because
almost every time i get asked are you
you know what's your social media handle
and i'm like no i don't have a social
media
presence so i've touched on that
numerous times
and um though the final point i'll make
on it is
love was early last year i call it
march april there was a
an online media publication here in
south africa that actually
did their own investigation right
unwarranted i didn't ask them to do so
as a matter of fact
they they they always write negatively
against me
and they did their own investigation and
um they found that
that um username and and an account is
is was linked to an ip address so
obviously they did this their search and
that ipaddress was linked to
a gentleman and they published his name
and that gentleman exists
in whatever form that he exists um so
that was out in the public domain
and they they they put that up in on
their online
platform um to a point where some other
publications picked it up
and you know that was that was that so
if you look at what happened
a few days ago and which disturbs me is
the very same publication that did that
investigation is fueling um these
um these um accusations and saying that
my
account in relation to whatever else is
going on
has been saying all sorts of things and
fueling from flames of
um sorry fanning flames of of of
disunity
and anarchy and i'm like guys you are
the guys that did your investigation as
a matter of fact you know
if anyone knows you guys know that's not
my account why is it that you are you
are
continuing to to to give me an an unfair
call on this one so
i think for now that's that's that's the
social media
debacle on my side okay
so a lot of the i did a bunch of
research uh in preparation
and there's a slew of negative articles
out there
and a number of them do quote things
you've said
on social media from these
unverified accounts you're saying none
of those
okay is there a reason just this is kind
of a side topic
because there are more important things
to talk about but is there a reason that
you're not
on social media like maybe one way to
get ahead of
unverified accounts is to bring up is to
make a verified account
all right um let me let me start by
answering by with the statement you just
made
so i approached some social media
agents managers gurus and
they actually they did give me that um
that advice but what they say to me and
i'm not i'm not too familiar with them
the social media space i know from what
i understand from
friends of mine and that sort of thing
is that
if you are on social media and
especially if you are someone of
interest in whichever way
you need to be active and what i was
told is you need to post
at least two to three times a week
because you get the automatic
verification if you're obviously some
really big deal
and if not you get your your period
where they'll they'll check your account
you need to post
um every so often pictures um statements
quotes whatever it is that you post and
it's a three to four month period until
you get your blue tick
and my view is very simple i'm not
trying to be on social media um i
it's not a space that i i like existing
on i don't want to be on that space and
that's why i decided not to
and i don't want to be that guy that
just gets a verified account just to sit
idle
um my whole my whole my whole point is
you know i don't want to be on social
media verified or not
and that's purely because i was to to a
large degree i'm a private person
and i enjoy you know looking around
looking around i enjoy scenery a lot i
enjoy being
observant because i'm an observant
person and i
screen time is not is not my thing you
know so that that's my reason for not
being on social media social media
of any sort and i decided not to take um
that approach because
you know i don't want to be on social
media okay
okay uh let me see
okay so let's get to let's get to some
of the questions i had after reading
some articles just so you can address
them i'm also nervous
okay um
okay well let's start with let's start
with the
some of them i guess why are there so
many
corruption accusations right
so i touched upon it a bit early on but
i think
yeah yeah but but the reason why in my
this is my my take on the reason why is
um
some of the stuff that that i've done or
that i've been a part of
is um is is
is not usual when it comes to the status
quo the way things are done in south
africa from
um like i said and this speaks to the
the concept of a young black business
person in the country
um there's there's ceilings there's
glass ceilings for
for for young black business business
people in this country and
i feel like i've i've been one of the
few that's um broken through those
ceilings
um in in in the space of time and
in in in the nature that i believe
hasn't been done before
and it's obviously people don't
understand
how it's been done um and and and why
it's me that that's done so the quickest
um accusation that they can
put forward is political connectivity
right so it's a whole
um politically exposed person so your
father
has got proximity to power so you're
benefiting from
him being there by whatever contracts
and
tenders that exist in the public space
and my whole life i've been a private
business person i've actually stayed
away from
from from from the public space doing
business with government
i mean the only time that i've done i
mean you can't avoid not speaking to
government in the country because
the regulatory bodies that exist in the
country so if you're in the mining
sector
at some point you'll have to interact
with government it doesn't mean that
they're giving you any any contracts or
any favors which they haven't done
but you have to interact with them so in
that sense that has happened and then in
another case where there's been
um contracts of of certain nature was
when we did a transaction where we
brought over
a mining company um that is part of a
global group
and we inherited their contracts that
were government contracts with their
with the power utility
um in our country and you know that was
pinned on us saying hey you guys got
these contracts you're saying now guys
we bought into this contract this was
part of
the t's and c's when we brought over the
the actual operation
so people like pointing fingers um
i've i'm here i've always been here they
thought i'd run away
i was labeled the fugitive at some point
and i came back
when people didn't expect me to come
back but i said guys i'm here and i've
gone through the system
um i've answered whatever questions i i
need to answer
but i can't be um i can't let people
keep bragging on me and
and keep beating me up for for stuff i
haven't done and
you know i've stood up and i've mend up
two to the accusations
and they just keep writing the negative
articles um i'm unsubstantiated at most
times
and the times i say guys if that's what
you really feel and what you believe
then take me to task you can't accuse me
of doing stuff and keep writing
negatively
whenever you feel like you know you're
writing articles that will
that are untrue that are unfounded
and then you leave me looking like the
guy that's done something wrong
so i find that a bit unfair and i think
that's that's the basis for a lot of the
[ __ ]
the negative articles is my proximity to
my my old man who was who was in
government and just people not
understanding
um what what has been termed a an
unusual
meteoric rise in the economic specs
okay and then i think we should get into
what exactly and you went into it a
little bit but what exactly is happening
right now
with the writing and looting because i
read and who knows
what online is real and what isn't real
uh
but uh i've read a number of things
about your opinions of the writing and
looting or what you think
caused them so can you just delve into
that a little bit more about
what you think the causes were and
whether or not you support them
sure um i think for the benefit of your
viewers a lot of
the blame that is attributed to me is um
is from certain opinions that i've given
but the opinions not in their entirety
um redacted to
seven seconds of a video clip or one
other video clip or a sound bite
and um this is unfortunate so
my opinion let me give my opinion first
off of what it is before i get into
the merits of the demerits of it my
opinion is very simple
we were always going to get to this
point in south africa and that is
based on the history that we've had
there's
an infamous image i think from the time
magazine
i think it was around 2012 2013
maybe 2014 latest it was an aerial
um an aerial photograph of um
what is known as a richest square mile
in africa centen
um and then so it was a on the one side
of
the highway um um literally literally uh
an eight-lane highway on the one side
was
um lavish golf course and parks and
and and five bedroom homes you know and
then on the other side
uh shanti towns um in south africa we
know them as informal settlements so
this literally
homes some of them built uh with
corrugated iron
and and um parts of it is what we
had for the social housing called the
rdp the reconstruction and development
program that started post 94
in order to give people dignity um to
build them
what are called four roomed house houses
which are
small houses literally a a bathroom a
kitchen a lounge
and a bedroom you know and then you'll
find that
that house is inhabited by most houses a
minimum of
six or seven people you know people
don't have the dignity of of
bathing in the house without being in
full view of everyone else
and that sort of thing so on the other
side of the highway that's what exists
so the the the interesting but sad
picture that they're painted is the
disparity between rich and poor
and it's not something that you need to
drive to the outskirts of the city to
see
it's literally across the highway so why
i use that example
example is today we we find that
situation where you have
people that are living in in dire
conditions
in very desperate conditions um they
will go and work
in in these homes with heated floors and
big screen tvs and persian carpets
whatever it is
this is in the home they'll pay those
kids they'll they'll groom and grow
those kids and in the evening over the
highway they back to their leaking roof
um paraffin lamp lantern
and um and no heat you know so
that has been a multi-generational
occurrence that's happened so you'll
find
in that same setup um when these
settlements were built in this 60s
some of them the specific one known as
alexander was built probably a bit
earlier than that
maybe in the 50s so you'll have a great
grandmother
a grandmother a mother and a daughter
that have lived in the same conditions
since the 60s
there's peterson in 2021 and you have um
child-headed households where
a 12-year-old is growing the kids up in
in in their home
and they're expected to make do with
with nothing so why i say this moment
was always going to be upon us is
because we're not dealing with the real
issues of poverty in our country we
always focus on the economy and the
health of the economy the state of
of how south africa looks on the global
scale which is important don't get me
wrong
but if we're not dealing with issues of
poverty in our country that will impact
the issues of crime i mean it's not
secretly everywhere
issues of crime in south africa of a
crazy nature in relation to elsewhere in
the world
um and and the issues of unemployment
that stem from
the poverty that stems from from the
very same unemployment
so we've had what is obviously a failure
of not just government but
private sector and society at large to
deal with these issues
and all that's happening is a blame game
people trying to blame insurgencies on
individuals
myself being one of them um i was born
way after these places were built um you
know this poverty has existed before i
was born
and at the rate at which you're going
will be worse and will exist way after
i'm gone down the line
um so for for it to be blamed on on a
set of people or
a a political party it's more than just
that
um so there's been
lack of effort and i i i always say this
it's a lack of effort from everybody
from every racial grouping in the
country black white indian
um colored colored which is
multi-generational mixed race
there's been a lack of empathy for the
issue of poverty
so now where we stand today it's it's
it's become
um a question an issue of
us and them them being the the the
protesters
them being the looters um them being the
people that are destroying the economy
because they're burning down
factories right so i don't condone
looting i don't
condone destruction of of property as a
matter of fact
last year when it was happening at one
of the universities in this very same
state that we're staying quasi-natal
i went to the university i was in dubai
i actually traveled back i told them
guys this can't happen
protest and do so but you cannot
destroy property it's counterintuitive
it's counterproductive to what it is
that we're trying to do
because it's these institutions we found
them standing and we need to leave them
standing not for ourselves but for those
coming after us
so please don't burn down our our
libraries and our healthcare facilities
and that sort of stuff
that's what i've done and you know i
find it very strange that people would
say that all of a sudden now
i'm coming up and i'm trying to um spike
these these rights
so south africa has gone from
historically the politics of
what i call liberation and freedom so
that was during the apartheid period
up until 94 to the politics of of race
so if you are black you're expected to
vote up for a black party and if you're
white expected to vote for a wide party
and that has played out the way it's
played out up until now and we've
quickly come to the advent of
the politics of of class and that's
exactly what we're seeing where
we have people from all the different
race groups looking at these people
labeling them looters and criminals once
again
the mob that has been um clearing uh
cleaning up the stores and stealing
bicycles and ovens and microwaves and
flat screen tvs
are poor people have they been elements
of criminality 100
i don't understand how people can burn
down a structure a factory i mean you've
taken what you need to take why are you
burning down
these structures as a matter of fact
where do you start bringing down a
factory factory there's a massive
um infrastructure so there are obviously
some some
some some untoward things that are that
are happening because
i find it very strange that these
structures have been burnt down
all over the show but that being said
the the excuse that people are making is
that people's hunger should not drive
them to destruction
you know people are not destroying it's
a certain grouping a
certain handful of people it's not
everybody and um you know so i don't
open this point i i just
took a round off i spoke to um a
grouping of journalists a few days ago
and they all happened to be black
journalists and i said to them
fellas just put your pens down and just
i just need to
to just say this i'm not looking for
your opinion or your response but
we all know by this weekend
um if we go to any of these informal
settlements or townships that we have we
all have families by the way whether
it's a cousin and auntie
um a nephew or niece a grandmother we
all have these
um these these relatives that even that
live in these
these um settlements
so townships would be like projects i
think i think that would be
uh yeah sort of description in south
africa
um if we go there we will find
bicycles outside in the garden we will
find tvs and microwaves inside
our family's homes that i can guarantee
i speak for myself as well
so that that speaks of the deeper issue
and that speaks of the bigger problem
and it's something that everyone is
running away from and trying to blame on
insurgency
and um and and um unruly and
an unruly mob the majority of the people
in this country live in abject poverty
and what is happening from a protesting
perspective
there's no surprise the looting is
unacceptable i
condemn it it's absolutely unfortunate
what has happened and is
as is not on for what it is because the
very same people that are destroying
the infrastructure the the supply chain
is going to impact
not just them but all of us so we're all
in this mess together
and it should be taken as an opportunity
for us all to come together like
everyone came together to protect
their homes their businesses and their
families regardless of what
racial denomination they're from we
should take that same ideology
that same energy to take this country
forward and stop blaming
everyone including the government but to
blame ourselves
because we are creating an us and them
situation and that will further fan
issues of poverty which is quickly
turning to issues of
of race because now they're the issues
of race that have popped up from the
different communities because of
how they've been some heavy-handed
responses to water-turned looters
okay
is there what can be done
to get south africa out of the state
it's in right now
like are there steps that you would
suggest that people could take
sure uh miss peterson i think the very
first thing we need to do
um because you know it's all about us
understanding each other so there needs
to be a certain level of a
um and not from from a religious kumbaya
perspective but from uh
we need a spiritual revolution we all
need to understand that
we are all in this together um this
problem is not going to be fixed by
anyone else there are people sending
messages out to the united nations
um to the u.s to the uk
come help us win dire straits that's not
going to happen not be
have to help ourselves we can't rely on
everyone else to come and sort our
problems out
and as you see that's what what's
happening in in western europe we've
seen
the the flash floods in germany and the
netherlands
um and parts of um i think belgium as
well
people have their own issues to deal
with besides the colgate issues
so we need to stop pointing fingers we
need to
reflect we need to introspect and we
need to say to ourselves guys
the issues we have are real these issues
are historic we haven't dealt with them
as a starting point
the issues of poverty and the issues of
of um
of of race relations um in this country
as a matter of fact the issues of
tribalism as well
um so the the the black and black issues
that we have from a tribalistic
perspective
in south africa um these are these are
discussions that we need to have
and these are understandings that we
need to get out of the way quickly
because if we don't do this
as a people as one people then we're not
going to get anything right
once we've done that once we've
acknowledged that guys we are all at
fault
not just me everybody's at fault because
we've all turned a blind eye
to the poverty because we're all
comfortable in our lavish homes
in the gulf estates and and eco and
forest estates so if the problem is not
on our doorstep
it doesn't matter now for the first time
this unfortunate situation
has made everyone realize that we're all
vulnerable
we're all vulnerable to to the situation
that we all need to take stock of it
now i can't sit here and then try and
deal with an issue with someone that's
going to be insulting me and then
hurling racial slurs at me for what they
believe i've done wrong
for the color of my skin or because of
the sonar the surname i carry
um you know i'm a grown man i can take
insults i've taken themselves before
you know that's not that's it's not what
i'm worried about but the problem people
have is
once you start labeling me a certain
name according to the color of my skin
or whatever it is you're not
just insulting me you're insulting the
majority of this country
and people need to realize that so we
need to watch what we say to each other
and we need to be safe with with with
the actions because
the repercussions will be dire we're
seeing certain
um quite intense um
racial issues popping up in certain
areas that people are struggling to
to contain so it's not like i'm speaking
from a prophetic
position and this is this is the reality
and then secondly
um we just need to feed people people
are more rational people are more
amenable to information and direction
on a fair stomach they don't have to be
full
they just need something in in their
stomachs to understand okay
we can we can start resolving these
issues so
it's going to be issues it's going to be
a three-fold exercise in in the interim
it's it's education based and not
necessarily from
a schooling perspective because we'll
get there but just from a
socializing this idea amongst each other
that um we're all
one and we all need to work um together
um secondly
it's it's it's a it's a welfare base we
need to get our people fit as i've said
so there's certain
grants systems that uh should be in
place but are not
which is unfortunately a failure of
government um
about a year ago when the the covert
lockdowns um happened globally there
were certain
funds that were put into place to try
and alleviate
pressure on on citizens and businesses
so there's no issues and obviously
taking care of the most vulnerable the
the elderly and the poor and there was a
bit a budget of
um in our currency 500 so half a
trillion
in our currency and and in rents and
that hasn't been seen it hasn't
translated to the common man or
on the common man as they call and that
is a problem
and this is part of part of the issue so
welfare needs to be we need to feed our
people right now we need to be on the
drive
to make sure that people have something
to eat um
and then finally is is um
the um the the economy so there needs to
be um
an enterprise play as well and and this
cannot be
um beneficial to a a handful of people
which it has been
historically um we need to open up
opportunities we
need to open up um business and the
economy to people that it hasn't been
opened up to before
um so we need to have a situation where
there's more competition created
there are more businesses running
smaller businesses once while small to
medium enterprises running
so that there's people that not only
um have businesses that they own but
they create opportunities for
people further down the chain in their
communities and that sort of thing so i
think that's a three-fold
approach um to start with at this point
in time
are you in politics i
i am not um this was a decision that i
made
the beginning of 2020 so i'm new to
politics and and
the reason why i got involved in
politics is because um i want to
i want to be the change that i see in
this country and you know i'm not trying
to sound
like i'm some um philosophical gentleman
because i'm not but i'm a practical
person um i'm a
a a grounded person so you know i got my
ten toes down at all times and
understand what the
issues are on on on the street and
what i feel is our politicians within my
own party as well political party
and others um so generally across the
board i've lost touch
with um with the people in this country
and i've lost touch with the reality
on the ground in this country and i want
to be part of a game-changing play which
i
currently am and i'll continue to be um
and i've
met i've mentioned my ambitions and
where i'd like to
to be so i can make these these changes
um quickly
and effectively okay
well i think we covered a lot i had a
whole bunch of
questions here but i think you pretty
much
covered i think you pretty much covered
all of them
without me asking them directly yeah
um is there anything else you want to
talk about or you want to let people
know because i know
from the research i've been doing yes
like you said there have been
sound bites taken out and
like i don't know anything about south
africa to tell you the truth
so like i don't know what's real or
what's not but um
if you're having you're on here having a
conversation right now is there anything
else you want to talk about and let
people know
yeah sure no i think um the first thing
that i want to do
what i want to say is i do not condone
violence or violent actions in any sort
now however i do not
support excessive protesting in the form
of looting and destruction
in whichever shape wave form and what
has happened in our country today is
completely unacceptable
um this is the time for us to um to band
together
and to to really deal with the issues at
hand and
we have to do it um from from a
harmonious perspective
i think we've all been going in our
different directions um
a lot of us may see things differently
but we all want to see
the same outcomes which is so which are
um peace and prosperity um as well as
um just safety and security i mean
that's
that's all we want the how you know
people have got different ideas and how
to get there
we just need to find out our way to the
middle ground
and there's a lot of messaging that i've
put out before and
i'll touch upon a few things since since
you asked me too
so there's this media in this country
that has
has always been um
quite interesting to some of us and me
specifically
um for example as as i as i'm
i'm speaking to you now there's there's
been a mute on and i can see what's
happening and it's you know it's been
for the past few years but specifically
now
where they've created this hype they've
created this um
this narrative that's out in in in the
public domain
um locally and internationally based on
the lie
and i'm finding it difficult to
put my version of events out there to
what should be
uh free and fair media um so there's
been a media mute on on and i'm speaking
for myself because i can only do so
um and i find this unfortunate because
people have already jumped to
conclusions and that time will come when
they'll realize that what has been said
and the blame apportioned to me
is not true i'm not expecting any
apologies i don't want any apologies
that's not what i'm here for
i want us to progress and get to a point
where we all understand each other and
we
we just keep it moving um so on on the
media front
um i find it unfortunate that they
they they fanning or they they are
progressing the life quite quite rapidly
um because i see the
the the the mind state of south africans
right now people are emotional
and they have they have the right to be
emotional um people
are apprehensive people are anxious um
we are all
it's not just um other people that's
myself as we all want to get out of this
and i think what has further exacerbated
this issue is the issue of
of the lockdown in south africa
specifically and speaking on messaging
um a year ago when we had the first
batch of or the first phase of lockdown
which is a 21 day that's when the world
locked down
on that period when everyone did it
almost simultaneously
i came up publicly and i said i think we
only have
this first phase however long that face
last phase last sorry
and that ended up lasting i think three
months or something four months
and i said after that it's going to be
difficult to affect lockdown in the
country why
we are taking and what we do
best in this country is we follow other
people's lead
leads sorry um we do not come up with
our own solutions you know
i'm always saying you know um african
solutions for african problems because
we can't take what works
in in in the us or what works in canada
or what works in
in in the uk or in
china and try and implement it here it
doesn't work like that
our socio-economic conditions in south
africa are completely unique to
most places in the world um based on
on on our breakdown of the traditional
and cultural practices and norms as well
as
our racial denominations so for us to
have instituted that lockdown when we
did
i think was a one
and only opportunity we had and a year
later i still believe that um and i
think one of the reasons we got to this
point
where we're at with south africa is is
being um
painted in this negative light um
internationally based on
on apparently or allegedly what what
i and some other people would have done
which is not true once again
um is a lockdown so there are people who
are being taken into a further state of
poverty
so now poverty does not does no longer
carry
um a blackface in in south africa
now there's indian faces there's wide
face faces that are popping up because
you have um people that have been
sitting
who've created their businesses who've
developed their their
their brands over a period of time in
whichever sector um
in the hospitality the restaurants um um
sector entertainment um people with with
law firms i mean everyone has had to sit
at home
and it's difficult to operate from home
you can't do everything over
microsoft teams or zoom or skype or
whatever it is
um and this has created a situation
where people haven't been able
to earn and the people that used to earn
um
a whole lot and are earning much more
well much less and they're people that
are not only at all so for the average
south african
um you know i think 80 probably of south
africans
who live um in in
in what would be the lower lsm would be
so basically what you you earn that day
is the food you put on the table that
evening so if someone doesn't work that
day they don't eat that
that's a reality on the ground in south
africa
and what people fail to do and whichever
city you are in in south africa
you take a maximum you jump in your car
and drive
half an hour maximum in any direction
you will come across
a township slash project um
or more importantly an informal
settlement which is a shanty town
and if you take a walk amongst the
people and see what's happening i can
guarantee you all these people
that are insulting and all these people
that are saying no you're siding with
criminals
and looters and that sort of thing will
change their minds because
the level of poverty that exists there
is unbelievable
and it's only a matter of time before
that poverty engulfs
everyone that thinks that they're living
away from it and are
insulated from this poverty it's going
to happen so when i say it's going to
happen people think that i'm being
insightful i'm like guys what
the hell do you expect we cannot ignore
this problem because it's been festering
and it's not an issue of myself uh my
my fake account um rallying up the
troops to do all this
crazy stuff um it's not there's not a um
and i actually even i even asked the guy
so
um if if my father was arrested because
apparently this is
a direct consequence of his um
incarceration
i asked i asked a few people and it was
a rhetorical question and i'll ask it
here again
and i'll answer it of course is if we
were not in the middle of a lockdown and
mr jacob zuma got locked up
would we be seeing the the unrest that's
happening in our country today my answer
is
hell no most definitely not would they
be protests
yes it'd be pro and anti-protest
happening but
would we be seeing the large scale
carnage that we've been seeing um over
the past week
most definitely not there's no one's
going to argue that point to
i'm very firm on that belief so that's
one of the reasons why i've called for
for also another element of a solution
to say lift the lock down for now let
people get back to work and i'm not
taking covert lightly don't get me wrong
i've lost people as or like everyone
else um but
we're not going to outrun and we're not
going to our staff covered in this
country so you can't
let people sit at home indefinitely and
not expect it to be these issues
so i've i've called for for the lifting
of the lockdown wasps
the very same government gets their
house in order um there's a vaccine
rollout um
the program that um and if you don't
know what's um since you don't know
what's happening
i'll tell you real quick uh we're here a
year behind the vaccine rollout program
um and i get concerned when i when i see
like everyone else um where the rest of
the world is and we're seeing in in the
us and this was last week when i was
watching
on the us news networks cnn more
specifically so
um and they'd mentioned that pfizer is
developing a booster
vaccine because the current vaccine
seems to be
getting less potent for for what it's
meant to do
now i'm thinking to myself if that's the
case for a country that's a year into
the program
and the population whatever is just over
half
the population vaccinated and we're
still way behind that program where will
we be in a year's time
so all the efforts that we're putting
into the vaccine now because we missed
about a year ago because there were
funds that were misappropriated
and that's a fact we're left in the
situation where the very same population
is going to suffer
so all i've said is guys whilst you're
getting your your your house in order
let people live
let people go out and let them carry on
with their lives of course social
distancing
and sanitizing and and um wherever you
can limit the numbers of gatherings and
that sort of thing but
you can't tell someone that has built a
coffee shop or restaurant
has spent their money their time their
lives building and you tell them
to to limit the capacity to 75 percent
or 50
and the next thing you're saying okay
only takeaways
what do you expect these people to do it
doesn't matter from what walk of life
um they're from um and and you know
that's that's something that
um i've taken my criticism for because
i'm apparently being
um i'm seen not to be taking covert
seriously and that's the furthest thing
from the truth i'm being realistic
because we're creating a far bigger
issue not now but down the line
that's going to be created from from
what is happening and we're seeing
um that the what i think is is the
beginnings of it if we do not deal with
the situation correctly
okay wow thank you for coming on the
podcast
telling me all this quite a lot of
information i'm a
i'm a little bit shocked no it's it's
it's
things get better that sounds good they
will be terrible
yeah they will get better on the
speeches and i think although the one
thing that we've fallen prey to in this
country is
misinformation um so there's there's
uh on whatsapp groups and even some
social media platforms
um from what i've seen the their voice
notes and um
so there's clips of going around video
clips of how people have been treated
so um armed groupings are protecting the
neighborhoods that were that shocked
innocent people and you'll find the
people being shot
are black people so the innocent people
being protesters and looters
and criminals and i try to stay away
from labeling these people criminals and
looters because
these are people that have been left no
choice um and i think that's where
people are losing are losing me and
what i'm the point i'm trying to get
across is we can't have
a situation that's rampant which is
poverty um people
have no options so they do what they do
and then we call them criminals
and i'm just speaking purely from the
pure protest and the person that's
stealing food i'm not talking about the
luther that's burning down stuff
and causing destruction we also need to
seize and desist from calling
people back because people are listening
um once again people can see it we're
creating an us and a damn story and
we don't want to get to that to that
point where um the the the poverty
stricken and
the the people that are seen as as
non-desirable people in our society
because they they have not
um start causing problems like they have
been causing
um so i just i always just
try and and stay away from creating
these labels and i think that's why
people are
are trying to come down hard on because
these are my people
i'm always going to be pro-poor i'm
always going to represent the poor
because
it's easy to talk when you don't face
those situations or you don't interact
with people
with those issues you know i'm not i'm
not trying to be
a a florence nightingale or mahatma
gandhi but i'm being realistic these are
the issues
and we need to deal with these issues so
society just needs to to acknowledge a
lot of stuff a lot of people are getting
away with turning a blind eye
and they need to be held accountable and
i'm talking about all of us including
myself
and this political journey that i'm
going on is part of trying to be
um sorry is this part of the solution
that i'm trying to
to to um initiate because i feel like
things are
being done at a slow pace um things are
being ignored and
i want to be that guy that that changes
things completely
um so all the negativity going on and
and
and the finger pointing and you know i
mean i've been called names i've been
threatened
um there's these people that are saying
all sorts of fancy stuff
um that's unnecessary we've got a
country to fix and you know we'll fix it
together i'm not worried about what they
say
it's unfortunate um and it's it's one of
those things that
we we're gonna get past and um this is
the final final point that i want to
make
i'm not sure how much time we have left
um but
there's there's an interesting um video
that i put out that
you know people came down hard on me and
i was explaining to people why
people are upset that my father's been
locked up
and this is what i and i'm paraphrasing
now because i don't remember the exact
wording that i used but i said to them
um
the reason why people upset of
for for jacob zuma being arrested is not
is is nothing but him being a symbol of
hope
and him being someone that people have
vested their interest in
um he's someone that is seen as
he holds people's hopes and aspirations
within him why because he's been that
story of someone that came from nothing
to the the highest
position of power in the country as best
for the presidency is politically
speaking
so they look and they say look if this
can happen to this guy
who is seen as one of us who has
fought for all of us because he's been
seen as a pro-poor
politician and a poor human being his
whole life including during
his tenure in the presidency they're
like
no we we can't have that and then that's
why people
have been writing for for him um have
always written for him and will continue
writing from so
i use that example to say to people it's
it's less
of um legal and jurisprudence matters
and judicial processes it's more of
humanity
and and how people view um someone that
they
they like and i mean there's the
allegations and stuff that he has to
account for an answer for
um true or false you know like i said
i'm not going to get into the merits of
demerits
but the way this specific one was done
is what a lot of people take issue with
i myself take issue with um for for the
basis of his
his um constitutional rights being
violated and
the the only point i'll use on that is
his right to a fair trial
um i think it's the first time we've
seen someone um it's
actually the the um
ironic thing is he is
so he's he was locked up in his early
political activism days he spent 10
years in robin island as well
so he is the first political prisoner
that's been locked up
in the apartheid days and post-apartheid
so he's he's got that in the books
and and secondly um he's the i think the
previous
person that's been um incarcerated
age-wise was
eldest would i say was 75 he's 79 years
old
so he's the eldest prisoner
at the moment and um
yeah all that without a fair trial he
hasn't had a trial and all i say to
people is
um just let him out let him have his
trial he's been sentenced to 15 years
who knows you might just find him guilty
in sorry 15 months who knows you might
find him guilty of
of whatever it is you're accusing him of
and you might sentence him to
15 years but give him that opportunity
to defend himself and if he's found one
thing then
you've got him in for much longer time
and you know that's that's my only my
only concern and myself
as as as as my own um being
i've i've also had my my criticism of
how
the south african legal system has
handled my cases has handled me
i've been here before i've been
wrongfully arrested
three years ago two and a half maybe
three years ago and this was based on my
um corruption cases um and the the the
interesting thing is
and as you know from from a legal
perspective in order for
a child to be drawn up in and for an
arrest to happen
there needs to be a basis which is
normally what they call the
well in south africa at least according
to our roman dutch law
um an a1 statement which is the the the
affidavit the basis that um the person
alleging the crime
will draw up and and submit there was no
a1 statement till today there is no a1
statement for my rest as a matter of
fact the person that
um that said had put up the a1 statement
himself said
it wasn't me um so you know
they still have to answer for that um i
haven't gotten those answers
um there was a it was actually funny a
what do you call it an online bounty so
they had an online bounty on my head a
wanted poster it doesn't sound that
funny
it did not it is because i mean it was
it was myself and one of my former
business partners and
in in rands which is a south african um
currency it got up to about
2 million ram so
yeah about 250 300 000 at that time
and you know this what people don't
understand it causes
unnecessary an unnecessary chain of
events because
my life is put at risk so you know
people now
citizens arrest and you know people get
a bit excited with these sorts of things
um and i find myself in a similar
position now where i've been made
public enemy number one for what's
happening in south africa
um and when we get to that point where
people realize
um when law enforcement agencies realize
that that's not the case
what's going to happen you're going to
apologize to me it'll be too late
my my my my persona my profile keeps
taking
serious hits you know the tinks in my
arm but i'm still standing you know but
you know it's all good
i'm not crying about what i'm just
saying people just need to be a bit more
careful
and and they need to be a bit more
researched because you cannot take
a seven second clip that you see making
the rounds
in relation to and to an eleven and a
half almost twelve minute clip
of me stating a few things as a matter
of fact that
that that certain clip that's making the
rounds that's caused
um and besides a fake social media
account um that's caused all this um all
this drama
um i recorded about three days into the
social unrest and so
sorry the civil unrest in south africa
and the reason why i recorded it
is recorded it is because i wasn't and
still now i'm not
being given a fair shake by the media so
that was my attempt
to try and get to the public information
to say guys all right this is me
this is a situation i'm not responsible
for what is what has happened
um this is my view on my father's
incarceration
the social media account not me um
and this is my view on what's happening
in in in in society right now that's
unacceptable and and
and and out of that whole 11 and a half
minutes they took that
um seven second um portion
completely out of context because i was
making a point and if you look at what i
was saying
it was actually a point that um that was
that was quite relevant we were saying
that people who are armed up
and are protecting themselves should um
do so responsibly
um and then i was trying to mention like
i said i i
i try not to turn people looters and
criminals i think it was taken out of
context
unfortunately but it is what it is i
guess
well we'll put this up and see what
happens i think i can
get it out tomorrow that was a hell of a
story
so i hope things improve
um yeah i i hope that you know if
there's any other questions that you
need to ask i'll probably
talk so i really like you covered
everything i had written down
so i think we're good i'll just release
the whole thing
cool tomorrow and we'll see what happens
miss peterson this is the first it's not
the first interview i've done but this
is the first
time in i think ever
i've got an opportunity to just rattle
off and in any interview
podcast i've done bbc interviews
this is the first time that i've been
given an opportunity uninterrupted
to to say what i need to say and this
means a lot to me
um i i highly appreciate it thank you
very much
okay well yeah thank you very much
thank you for having me
you